alors ce sont des faits qui remontent
effectivement au 3 août et autres en
début août 2010 8 août c'est tout alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à l'époque
gérard depardieu avait 69 ans la victime
présumée qui s'appelle charlotte arnould
on avait 23 jeux
gérard depardieu était en fait un ami un
vieil ami de la famille puisqu'il
connaissait le papa de la victime
présumée depuis plus de 40 ans et ils se
sont rencontrés le 2 août avec la maman
de charlotte ils se sont ensuite rappelé
et gérard depardieu aurait proposé
d'aider charlotte à percer dans la
comédie dans le milieu théâtral et donc
lui aurait proposé de venir chez lui
dans son hôtel particulier du 6e
arrondissement pour lui donner quelques
conseils et là lors de ce rendez vous
les choses auraient dégénéré selon le
rapport de police d'accord alors
derrière donc celle donc comme vous
l'avez dit le 7 août 2010 huit corps
yeux la première agression deux temps
d'abord dans le salon de l'acteur puis
dans une chambre à l'image de son
domicile une semaine après ils sont
revenus alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans le salon et dans la chambre alors
dans le salon ils commencent ils parlent
donc hipark théâtre là dessus il lui dit
c'est ça c'est ce que raconte la
présumée victime
c'est ce que raconte la présumée victime
et gérard depardieu lorsqu'il a été
confronté à la victime en moins de
novembre se suivent en a qui essaient
qu'il avait bien eu cette conversation
qu'il avait mis à parler dans ce genre
de choses avec elle et qu'il y avait
bien eu des actes sexuels de ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là c'est qu'ils ont
commencé à parler pendant cinq minutes
de voilà de théâtre il lui a dit qu'il
se serait bien qu'elle qu'elle apprenne
les femmes savantes de molière et puis
la tuile lui dis oh là là vous me faites
penser à barbara est ce que vous pouvez
vous approchez que je regarde votre
maquillage vous avez deux jours lisieux
est là selon le rapport de police et la
victime présumée le choses auraient
dégénéré et gérard depardieu aurait
glissé cema sous les vêtements de
charlotte et là s'en serait suivie
excusez moi du terme une pénétration
digitale
c'est à dire avec les doigts et c'est
l'intervention en fait ça veut dire
digital mais au cas où il me dit que
tout n'est que c'est une histoire
d'ordinateurs
est donc là dessus la femme de ménage
arrive donc la jeune femme qu'il faut
savoir que cette jeune femme est quand
même une jeune femme anorexique toute
fine qui du coup ne fait pas le poids
face à gérard depardieu
donc là la femme de ménage arriver là
gérard depardieu lui aurait proposé à
aller visiter les jardins de son hôtel
particulier et ils se seraient arrêtés
devant une chambre et là la victime se
serait exécuté selon ses propos et ce
sera aller dans cette chambre se serait
allongée et aurait subi contre sa
volonté un cunnilingus de la part de
gérard depardieu d'accord donc ça c'est
donc voilà donc ça c'est la première
fois la première c'est la première fois
donc j'en parle en deux temps donc et et
dernière une semaine après cette
présumée agression le 13 août 2010 8 la
jeune comédienne aurait seront loin elle
était prise dans un mécanisme de
sidération et de dénis et serait
retournée au domicile de l'acteur est ce
que c'est vrai que celle qu'il aurait
rappelé alors c'est elle qui qui qui
n'ont dans un premier temps la première
fois c'est là la deuxième fois c'est
gérard depardieu qui l'a appelé pour lui
demander si elle avait travaillé les
femmes les femmes savantes et lui a
proposé de revenir de revenir la voir
donc de revenir le voir pardon et là
dessus elle ce qu'elle a dit aux
enquêteurs selon un rapport de police et
qu'elle y est allé pour lui dire ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle pensait de ce qui
s'était passé juste avant et qu' il
avait commis l'irréparable
sauf que là une deuxième fois il y
aurait eu un nouveau viol une agression
sexuelle avec une nouvelle pénétration
digitale ce que nie totalement gérard
depardieu il skie pas le cunnilingus il
dit même qu'il s'est arrêté de de faire
cet acte parce qu'elle n'y prenais pas
de plaisir mais nie totalement les
pénétrations digitales excusez moi du
terme parce que cette jeune femme était
vierge et que jamais ne se serait permis
de faire tout ça et que pour lui la
victime était totalement consentant
revenu le voir alors on va rappeler donc
eux
cette affaire complexe un détail et me
par le parisien alors le contexte de
leur rencontre donc comme vous l'avez
dit gérard depardieu c'est un ami de
longue date de la famille de charlotte
arnould jeune comédienne il est comme
vous l'avez dit il avait croisés
auparavant la plaignante et sa mère dont
l'acteur est proche et c'est la mère de
charlotte un collègue qui donne le
numéro de sa fille à l'acteur afin
qu'ils lui donnent des conseils pour sa
carrière ensuite à 7,7 ce premier rendez
vous avez dit le 7 août et ensuite selon
la jeune femme donc gérard depardieu se
serait subitement mis à passer sa main
sous ses vêtements comme vous l'avez dit
elle lui a imposé des attouchements au
niveau des parties intimes charlot tard
nous dénonce aussi une pénétration comme
vous l'avez dit digital elne assure
n'avoir pas su comment réagir tétanisé
choqué par la tournure des choses et le
parisien vous me rappeler le contexte
psychologique dans laquelle la jeune
femme se trouvait comme vous l'avez dit
à l'époque c'est une jeune femme fragile
elle n'a aucune expérience sexuelle
ressent d intérêt pour les hommes et se
remet d'une anorexie handicapante ni un
traumatisme d'enfance
ensuite est ce que c'est c'est vrai que
lcl qu'il aurait rappelé aussi derrière
alors c'est ça qui va qui va permettre à
gérard depardieu de se défendre c'est
que étrangement déjà les vidéos de
surveillance dieu de l'hôtel particulier
montre une jeune femme à la sortie de
cette agression plutôt calme plutôt
sereine voire même souriante et rigolant
donc voilà c'est un peu troublant
ensuite elle va également lui envoyer
des sms en lui disant que voilà la
travailler la fameuse pièce de théâtre
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et qu'
elle aimerait bien chanter avec lui au
cirque d'hiver lui laisse un message
pour lui dire qu'elle aimerait bien
chanter du barbara au cirque d'hiver et
du coup oui c'est assez intriguant c'est
intrigant il ya même amène qu'elle a
donné qu'elle a envoyé à fanny ardant
avec qui elle tourner une comédie où
elle dit oh là là gérard depardieu quel
homme donc forcément les enquêteurs sont
intrigués par ça et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça peut-être que le rallye ce
pourra nous l'expliqué que la première
fois quand le défaut de play ça a été
fait le 25 août 2010 8 les enquêteurs
n'ont pas non aux arrêts telle enquête
en disant que les faits ne permettait
pas d'être sérieux et 2 et de prouver et
de couverts viol alors ils filent vers
le oui ce qui est très étonnant c'est
que l'afer a été une première fois qu'il
a c'est sans suite ces ca 9 mois d'
enquête en 2019 et c'est vrai qu'il ya
deux faits qui avait attiré l'attention
des enquêteurs
c'était donc le sms que charlot tard
nous envoie après le 13 août monde où
gérard j'ai appris la scène et j'espère
la travailler avec toi elle parle des
femmes savantes de molière donc là les
enquêteurs ont dit vous reprocher deux
faits graves et après vous envoyez un
sms et elle avait répliqué je voulais
expulsé la mort qui m'habite j'étais en
déni de ce qui s'était passé et ensuite
il ya ces caméras de surveillance qui
c'est vrai la montre souriante alors
elles ne sont pas à l'état mais les
enquêteurs lui avait dit vous reprocher
des faits graves et vous sortez en
souriant et elle avait dit pareil
j'étais en état de protection mentale
total donc les enquêteurs avaient tiqué
et puis l'affairé a été classée elle a
porté plainte une nouvelle fois hélas il
est mis en examen la fer se poursuit il
faut préciser que lui dit qu'il est
innocent alors justement gérard
depardieu dit voilà dos lors de son
audition libre à la poésie parisienne
gérard depardieu a reconnu avoir touché
la plaignante de son initiative et
l'avoir interrogé sur ces abus sexuels
mais il a team que la jeune femme était
pleinement green sont tendus senti dans
son regard et son comportement une
curiosité et une otan qui m'ont poussé à
aller plus loin il va de soi que si
j'avais senti la moindre résistance
opposition elle n'aurait pas eu besoin
de dire un mot j'aurais immédiatement
arrêté m'ayant dit qu'elle était vierge
je n'ai à aucun moment voulu partir d
une pénétration digitale
lors du premier rendez-vous lorsqu'ils
sont allés taj et capteurs procédera
cunnilingus comme me l'avait dit tout à
l'heure gérard depardieu demande à la
plaignante si elle ressent du plaisir
elle m'a dit non alors j'ai arrêté comme
nous l'avait dit on sue n est en aucun
cas de l'atteindre mais au contraire de
faire en sorte avec son consentement
d'essayer de lui donner du plaisir
imposer un acte sexuel est pour moi
quelque chose d'inconcevable et
d'insupportable
voilà et
et il les deux mais il ya trois choses
voilà qui sont les clés de voûte de la
de la défense pour contester le viol
donc vous l'avez dit les caméras de
surveillance a analysé voilà d'après le
parisien les enquêteurs notent que les
yeux les jours les jours des deux viols
à des journées de viol allégué charlotte
alors nous semble toujours calme plat je
me décontracter souriante discrète et
sans plomb parfois rire y compris
lorsqu'elles type le domicile ils disent
aussi le témoignage de la femme de
ménage la femme de ménage qui le 7 août
n'a pas constaté que la plaignante était
particulièrement bouleversé et 3 les
messages comme vous l'avez dit de
charlotte arnoux à gérard depardieu
voilà après le 13 août voilà monde où
gérard j'ai appris la scène et j'espère
la travailler avec vous bientôt voilà
s'élève à 10 et les explications de
charlotte arnould sur ces messages à
gérard depardieu parce qu'elle a été
entendu par la pj elle affirme kem ces
messages traduisent l inverse de sa
pensée dans l'un d'eux elle dit
d'ailleurs ce qu'elle passe là dans
l'après midi avec une amie pour couper
court à toute nouvelle invitation de
noir depardieu alors que c'est faux
j'avais besoin d'expulser le mal-être en
moi la mort qui m'habite at elle soutenu
je n'avais pas envie d'y croire encore
j'étais dans le déni la sidération la
dissociation je n'ai pas pris conscience
de la gravité des faits
aujourd'hui et elle a pris la parole sur
twitter mi décembre où elle dit
il travaille pendant que je passe mon
temps à survivre
c'est à ce moment là qu'elle a révélé
son identité puisque on n'allait pas le
nom de la psychologue qui l'examinent
révèle un récit raconté comme si elle
était spectatrice des scènes cela peut
être dû à un processus de défense
psychique de mise à l'état des affects
et ne présume en rien une affabulation
écrit l'expert en précisant que sa
fragilité psychologique
il ya son anorexie antérieures a pu
constituer un facteur de vulnérabilité
voilà gérard depardieu nie les faits son
ami farid khider boxeur professionnel le
défend bec et ongles voilà il est
aujourd'hui où on est là faire donc
qu'est ce qui va se passer le rallye est
bien pour le moment un gérard depardieu
a été mis en examen ça veut dire que
comme on en avait déjà parlé pour un ré
habitants un juge d'instruction a été
saisi qui dispose donc de la possibilité
de mener des commissions rogatoires
certaines mené son enquête de faire des
auditions d'entendre les différentes
parties d'entendre éventuellement des
témoins de demander des expertises pour
essayer de faire la lumière sur cette
affaire la difficulté en réalité ce
qu'il faut rappeler c'est que qu'on
parle de viol le violentait entendue au
sens large une pénétration du talent
c'est un viol ou une agression sexuelle
il faut deux éléments il faut une
absence de consentement et il faut une
contrainte une menace une surprise ou de
la violence est en réalité dans cette
affaire c'est toute la question du
consentement qui va poser problème parce
que c'est ce qui pose problème pour le
droit pour déterminer s'il ya ou non
consentement et c'est ce qui peut aussi
poser problème parfois pour les
protagonistes quand on est dans un dans
un bête qu'on a un homme qui est avec
une femme dans un bar parfois le
consentement va être implicite il va
sentir qu'il peut y aller et il va
l'embrasser et il n'a pas lui faire
signer un contrat ou lui demander est ce
que tu es d'accord que je t'embrasse
comme ça ne sera pas une agression
sexuelle et c'est toute la difficulté
parce que ce consentement implicite il
peut être perçu de façon différente en
fonction des deux parties la victime
présumée déclare qu'elle est en état de
sidération c'est pas quelque chose c'est
quelque chose qu'on connaît bien dans
les tribunaux 70% des victimes
d'agressions sexuelles et de viol sont
généralement état de sidération
c'est-à-dire qu'elles n'osent pas dire
non qu'elle n'ose rien faire et qu'elles
sont totalement tétanisée on le voit
souvent
d'un autre côté effectivement comme vous
l'avez très justement rappelé et comme
myriam l'a aussi rappelé on a des
éléments on a cette phrase gérard
depardieu qui dit j'ai senti dans son
regard et dans son comportement mac je
pouvais y aller et qu'elle était
consentante et on a ces éléments le fait
qu'elle revienne effectivement le
message qu'ils soient envoyés les
témoignages qui vont aussi devoir être
examiné par le juge d'instruction
j'aurai terminé ce qu'il en est
guillaume ont la clé de cette affaire
ses fictions le consentement est ce
qu'on considère comme une preuve de
consentement après les faits la gérard
depardieu il met en avant un
effectivement ses messages les caméras
de surveillance les témoignages de la
femme de ménage mais visiblement ce
n'est pas ou plus suffisant puisque le
fait de dire qu'on était en état de
sidération qu'on dise l inverse de sa
pensée eh bien ça peut faire douter de
cette affaire donc c'est une affaire qui
s'annonce extrêmement complexe et encore
une fois c'est parole contre parole donc
ça va être très dur de déterminer s'il y
avait consentement ou non la caisse
l'actualité brûlante là c'est que gérard
depardieu il contestait sa mise en
examen il disait il y avait une première
fois un non lieu
en et l'annulation est là et la cour
d'appel de paris hier a dit non on
valide et le juge d'instruction reprend
la faire il faut préciser que la seule
fois où il s'est exprimé publiquement
c'était dans la repubblica grands
quotidiens italiens et il a dit je suis
innocent donc lui ne varie pas de sa
ligne de conduite béatrice moi il est
présumé innocent moi je n'ai pas d'avis
voilà je voulais juste dire que c'est un
sujet extrêmement complexe que ce sujet
du consentement dans ce genre de cadre
et il ya une série qui est extrêmement
bien faite sur le sujet qui s'appelle
the morning show avec jennifer aniston
et reese witherspoon et c'est une série
que je recommande vraiment parce que
c'est un peu le même cas de figure c'est
un acteur enfin à présentateur très
connu qui se retrouvent au beau gosse
[Rires]
bien mais alors hissé tout s'est passé
soient versés sur sa clope est bannie
foulée faire de la promo pour des
talibans je mange pas de porc merci
alors oui oui mais après ce qu'il faut
c'est ce que va aussi certainement faire
ressortir la défense de cette jeune
femme c'est des propos que que gérard
depardieu a tenu en 1975 et qui avait
été déjà d'ailleurs repris en 1991 par
le new york times au moment où il le
coup il concourait pour pour l'oscar de
pour cyrano de bergerac ou à l'époque il
a avoué avoir avoir déjà commis des
viols et en avoir fait plusieurs donc ça
ça va aussi peser dans la balance et
c'est ce genre de choses va va ressortir
au moment où la victime va se défendre
oui il ya un témoin clé dans cette
affaire c'est la mère de charlotte qui
était une amie de gérard depardieu et
qui était la première personne que la
victime présumée a contactés après les
faits présumés elle expliqué qu elle
hurlait qu'elle était en pleurs et
malheureusement les policiers ne peuvent
plus interrogés parce qu'elle est décédé
entre-temps et le parisien explique que
cette affaire l'a profondément marqué
voilà c'était un témoin clé dans la
sphère d'accord oui d'autres choses
ville non en fait c'est vraiment on va
se retrouver à parole contre parole
parce que là contrairement à d'autres
affaires n'y a pas eu y'a pas un dossier
détaillé l'artiste médical ya pas et
parole contre parole c'est vraiment un
si je puis dire à l'appréciation du juge
d'instruction qui va faire son travail
avait une confrontation une seule
confrontation très tôt nul doute qu'ils
en ont marre à une autre des expertises
également est en fait la question qui se
pose c'est ce qu'il faut faire évoluer
le droit sur la question du consentement
est ce qu'il faudrait qu'on ait instauré
à un consentement exprès pour éviter un
consentement implicite ce qui me paraît
un peu compliquée oui avouez le rallye
ce que ça complique quand même les
relations entre les hommes et les femmes
parce que tu as peut être que cette
jeune fille à l'air très fragile
psychologiquement on parle de troubles
du comportement alimentaire anorexie
d'ailleurs c'est toujours un peu les
mêmes profils qu'on retrouve ici pas
dans le cas de marie habitants mais dans
ce patrick poivre d'arvor c'est toujours
un peu les mêmes profils toujours le
déni la sidération l'emprise donc ça
c'est toujours elle m'a appris comment
on va faire concrètement quand on va
avoir un rapport avec quelqu'un il y
aura quoi des caméras de surveillance on
doit on devra faire en signer une
décharge un contrat on ira devant
l'avocat avant de consommer mais ça va
être compliqué mais ce qui paraît
clairement noté stade ya des infos me
lève pas la moindre pudeur il pense qu'à
partir au ski avoriaz
son chagrin
dans ce cas précis ce qui était
intéressant c'est que la situation était
vécue de la même façon d'aider deux
parties avaient reconnu d'un côté comme
de l'autre mais vécue à postérité
différemment donc c'est un vrai problème
et concernant ce que ce que vous avez
dit sur votre sueur depardieu j'ai un
peut enquêter il n'a pas donné pas
l'habitation d'être un meilleur quand
j'ai pas dit ça c'est vrai que pas du
tout parvenant
souvent c'est vrai on a on a on a vu
plein de gens nous disent un
cv qui les faisons c'est quand même
assez cru que te parle de sexe mais
comme pas mal de gars ont semblé
reprocher non nous a dit qu il est
extrêmement dur djoman justement avec
les mets et les voilà donc c'est moi
j'ai posé deux j'ai appelé de trois
personnes c'est vrai que c'est pas la
réputation qu'il a maintenant encore une
fois on était suffisamment dur dans ce
qui me sont d'autres cas pour pas dire
voilà on croit on prend l'habitude mais
dans ce cas précis
insistons bien sur la glace la selle et
tvq est reconnu par les deux parties
mais vécue différemment après
géraldine imaginez que demain on puisse
faire signer des contrats en guise de
consentement doit aux etats unis c'est
déjà le cas vous avez des grandes
célébrités qui avant d'avoir des
rapports d'un soir avec des femmes lors
sans ciller les contrats qui sont des
vraies preuves concrètes de consentement
sauf que ça à des plats pardon ça
déplace le problème parce qu'on peut
dire qu'on m'a forcé
des caméras de surveillance partout
aussi exactement les chambres et tous
avait pas eu de crise c'est comme chez
vous oui c'est vrai oui
oui j'étais quasiment regarde annonce
partout sur un panel de sextape de
sextape ne faisait pas
[Rires]
on